[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue c'est lundi et le lundi on a de
la chance parce qu'on a souvent le
privilège de recevoir sur ce plateau
nicolas pas vrai et alexandre ii vecchio
bonsoir nicolas baverez vous êtes
économiste avocat essayiste chroniqueur
au figaro on retrouve chaque semaine
votre analyse dans les colonnes du
journal et dès la veille au soir sur le
site internet du figaro et je rappelle
le titre de votre dernier livre le monde
selon tocqueville combat pour la liberté
publié aux éditions tallandier bonsoir
alexandre vecchio
vous êtes l'un des hommes qui nous aider
à réfléchir au figaro
hutaree pour le figaro vox bien sûr
d'être aussi en charge des pages débats
du figaro magazine est votre dernier
livre recomposition le nouveau monde
populiste a été publié aux éditions du
cerf nous avons deux sujets au sommaire
de cette émission
dans quelques minutes on va reparler de
la mémorable cérémonie des césars de
vendredi dernier pour savoir jusqu'où on
peut descendre mais on va commencer par
l'actualité la plus immédiate
si vous le voulez bien c'est-à-dire
l'actualité sanitaire regarde les
informations très très paradoxale ou
contradictoires entre l'alarmisme d1
l'optimisme des autres on voit bien dans
quelques minutes mais l'actualité la
plus immédiate c'est l' annonce du
président de la république de suspendre
de façon très très propre provisoire le
l'administration du vaccin astrazeneca
vous savez qu'il y avait des soupçons de
d'effets secondaires qui pourraient être
graves
on parle de thrombose
beaucoup de spécialistes disent que
concomitance ne signifie pas
responsabilité du vaccin n'empêche que
après angela merkel emmanuel marc on
décide de lever le pied pendant 24
heures
est ce que c'est une décision sage
nicolas baverez ou est ce que c'est une
soumission
une fois de plus au principe de
précaution qui nous paralyse comprend
pas très bien la logique de cette
décision parce que de deux choses l'une
où on a maintenant sept pays européens
qui ont suspendu ce vaccin donc ce sont
des pays avec des autorités de santé
responsable donc visiblement il ya au
moins des doutes sérieux
donc si on veut l'élever il faut prendre
le temps c'est pas en 24 heures qu'on
saura si ces doutes sont fondées ou non
et à linverse s'il n'y a pas de raison
ou si on a regardé tout ce qui s'est
passé dans ces pays et qu'on considère
que effectivement il n'y a pas de lien
avec le vaccin
à ce moment là il faut continuer donc je
crois que la suspension de 24 heures me
laisse un peu pantois parce que si on
veut réexaminer le statut de ce vaccin
ça suppose que les différentes autorités
qui sont chargé d'homologuer prennent le
temps de regarder des éventuels
incidents et ça ça se fait pas en 24
heures donc les 24 heures me l'esm
me laisse perplexe et par ailleurs on en
soit c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
puisque la france est déjà très en
retard sur la vaccination il est clair
que si maintenant quoi qu'il arrive ya
les doutes qui existait dans l'opinion
sur ce vaccin mais aussi sur la
vaccination vont être renforcés par
cette décision
donc on va avoir deux problèmes qui vont
sur ajouter un problème de renouveler
disponibilité de vaccins si on a plus
que les fonds isr et modern art en
attendant johnson and johnson et par
ailleurs il est clair qu'on va avoir des
séquelles dans l'opinion de cette
décision de suspension pour 24 heures
qui en tout cas en tant que telle n'a
aucun sens peut-être qu'elle a un sens
politique alexandre de vêture plus que
sanitaire on sait qu'il reste partie non
négligeable des français qui est
réticente à laisser se faire vacciner
surtout avec l'astra zeneca y compris
chez les soignants
c'est une façon de dire je vous ai
compris voilà je vous rejoindra c'est ce
qu'a dit nicolas barrel si c'est
uniquement une suspension politique
enfin un politique communicationnelle en
fait c'est ça parce que politique c'est
autre chose ça ça n'aura pas beaucoup
d'intérêt bon aussi ci-après en 24
heures s'il s'agit d'un lot qui est
possiblement abîmé et c est que ça peut
se vérifier en vingt-quatre corps
pourquoi pas moi je suis techniquement
gpal expertise pour le dire je fais
confiance à nicolas baverez là dessus
bon à partir du moment où sept pays
européens l'ont suspendu c'est quand
même qui a des suspicions et donc je
pense qu là on n'est pas dans un excès
du principe de précaution on est juste
dans une forme de prudence et de sagesse
on va voir comment ça alexandre 13 ans
du jour mais il faut pas du tout me
faire cours pour vérifier
j'ai dit nicolas mouret mais pas qui des
mieux j'ai une séparation 5e mais il
faudra qu'elle soit un peu mais c est ce
qu on va on prend 24 heures pour
l'examiner à l'eau qui est suspect est
ce que c'est toute la chaîne est ce que
voilà en tout cas à partir du moment où
sept pays où il ya eu des cas même qui
ont conduit apparemment à la mort même
si on sait pas encore si c'est quoi
incidence ou au corrélation directe ça
paraît voilà prudent de suspendre et
cette prudence est une preuve de plus de
votre honnêteté intellectuelle
revenons un domaine qu'on connaît un
petit peu mieux qui est celui de la
gestion de cette pandémie
c'est très intéressant de voir à quel
point les voix sont discordantes et pas
seulement entre les médecins et les
politiques
il ya ceux qui disent attention ça va de
plus en plus mal parmi ceux-ci valérie
pécresse la présidente de la région ile
de france ce matin sur france 2 ile de
france est clairement sursis aujourd'hui
vous le savez le vario anglais est
majoritaire et ce variant il n'est pas
seulement plus contagieux il est aussi
plus mortelle nos capacités de
réanimation sont saturés et je profite
de votre émission d'ailleurs pour
remercier les régions de france
les pays de la loire la nouvelle
aquitaine qui ont accueilli ce week end
nos malades franciliens alors quasiment
au même moment mais sur un autre média
sur france info le patron du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux tenait un
discours beaucoup plus volontariste
c'était à se demander si ces deux là
vivent dans le même pays
avec surtout comme mon petit à petit
progressivement manière habile
sectoriellement on retire on baisse le
quoi qu'il en coûte
on peut pas vivre éternellement sous
perfusion de l'état ce qui est le cas
d'un certain nombre de secteurs
je crois que c'est ici des rejets
employer l'expression le monde d'avec je
constate avec satisfaction ça a été
repris par d'autres
il faut ouvrir vite mais accepter que
c'est pas tout à fait comme avant donc
les cinémas avec une jauge
alexandre vécu le medef dit il faut
ouvrir vite
la présidente de france dit il faut
fermer c'est peut-être inévitable 1re
confinement alors qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qui se passe là déjà il parle pas ce
sont deux émetteurs différeront qui ont
des contraintes peut-être différente
valérie pécresse parle en tant que
présidente de région
bon allez peut-être en lien direct avec
avec les hôpitaux pour qui la situation
semble commencer à être difficile même
si j'entendais aussi d'autres médecins
hospitaliers qui expliquait qu' on
pouvait créer des livres des lits
pérenne et qu'il y avait un manque de
volonté politique là dessus moi je ne
comprends pas ça fait un an qu'on s est
créé je le répète à chaque fois mais
pourquoi on n'a pas fait ça me paraître
des réflexes comptable totalement idiot
d'autant plus qu'on dépense des
milliards chaque jour effectivement pour
ce confinement est donc geoffroy roux de
bézieux se placer en tant que
représentant des patrons et on comprend
effectivement qui veulent que l'activité
reprenne le plus tôt possible
alors je pense que moi je suis pas un
obsédé de la question de la dette mais
je pense que quand on ouvre toutes les
vannes même pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas
obsédé elle va finir tout de même pas se
poser
et puis surtout on a des secteurs c'est
pas simplement une question de dette a
reposé mais des secteurs qui risquent de
disparaître tout simplement il parlait
des cinémas on est pays qui est le plus
de salles de cinéma au monde ou en
europe
les restaurateurs une partie des petits
commerces parce qu'il faut il faut pas
oublier que certains sont encore fermés
ceux qui sont dans les galeries etc
donc je pense que au delà même de la
question budgétaire il ya tout
simplement une question sur l'activité
la profonde mutation technologique en
plus avec les gars fin et c'est la
question c'est dans quel monde vous
qu'on vire à la sortie de la crise donc
je pense que les conséquences risquent
peut-être d'être sanitaires à terme et
en termes de lien social d'activité
économique plus terrible que le mal lui
même donc j'ai plutôt tendance à penser
comme geoffroy roux de bézieux suite moi
je suis pas médecin je pas à l'hôpital
et je sais pas si on est à la limite ou
pas eu réellement vous pensez aussi
comme la majorité de ceux qui le suivent
sur twitter ou de vous posant la
question pensez vous que le gouvernement
doit rouvrir les lieux culturels et
restaurants et les centres commerciaux
qui ont été fermés c'est oui à 66%
ce n'est pas l'unanimité pour autant
écouter françois sur youtube il faut
boucler re confiné sérieusement et au
régime strict tant que nous n'aurons pas
la couverture vaccinale nécessaire
il ne faut même pas envisager une
réouverture de quoi que ce soit à dld
aussi sur lefigaro.fr considère que le
pragmatisme et la sagesse appelle au
principe de précaution quant à karine
elle a résigné sur youtube nous sommes
tous voués à mourir par conséquent
autant vivre en attendant le vaccin
nicolas baverez est ce que vous êtes
dans le dans le parti des patrons ceux
qui veulent rouvrir
non mais il y ce boulet il ya quand même
un point de convergence entre ces deux
prises de position c'est le retard de la
france sur les deux plans l'opposition
entre le sanitaire et économique ne
tient pas parce que comme on l'a dit
quand on ferme pour les raisons
sanitaires on a d'énormes dégâts en
terme psychologique en termes de santé
puissent par ailleurs on arrête de
soigner les gens pour tout le reste
n'est
des pathologies et aussi évidemment en
termes d'économie donc la firme sur elle
et pas seulement coûteuse pour
l'économie elle est coûteuse pour la
santé et les coûteuses pour la société
je crois que c'est ce qu'on a commencé à
comprendre alors le problème c'est que
la reprise va avoir lieu et cette
reprise elle va être vigoureuse mais
elle va être extrêmement hétérogène
suivant les pays
et évidemment ce convoi en asie c'est
que ceux qui redémarre les premiers
auront évidemment une reprise beaucoup
plus forte
ça dépend de quoi ça dépend de la
situation sanitaire donc de la
vaccination
on vient d'en parler à des problèmes
quand même c'est que président de la
république je sais pas si cette décision
est bonne ou mauvaise mais en tout cas
celle inverse de ce que disait le
premier ministre il ya deux jours donc
il faut reconnaître déjà qu'en termes de
cohérence des pouvoirs publics
c'est quand même pas fameux la deuxième
chose c'est que sur l'économie il faut
avoir à la fois une bonne articulation
des plans de relance entre le court
terme et de moyen terme
et puis des plans de relance
suffisamment puissant et rapide et on
n'y est pas du tout en france
et puis il faut traiter le problème de
la compétitivité ont fait exactement
l'averse je rappelle que l'an dernier
la france a eu 65 milliards d'euros de
déficit commercial et que les
exportations françaises ont perdu 1,2
point de part de marché en europe
donc ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
aujourd'hui si on repart sans traiter
notre problème de compétitivité
on va faire la fortune des exportations
italiennes allemandes espagnoles et donc
c'est là-dessus où je pense qu' il
faudrait se mobilisent et je crois que
la vaccination doit rester une priorité
et il faudra faire la balance des
risques mais
est-ce qu'il est plus risqué de se faire
vacciner ou d'attraper le coc vide c'est
quand même là dessus qu'il faut
raisonner le team hm et sur la
réouverture il faut changer le logiciel
le logiciel de quoi qu'il en coûte et là
geoffroy roux de bézieux a absolument
raison
le quoiqu'il en tout coûte est en train
de ruiner l'économie l'état et la
société
on va se retrouver avec une dette
gigantesque des entreprises très
lourdement endettée des ménages qui
aussi seront endettés parce que faut
bien voir que les 120% du pipe ça veut
dire 36000 euros pour chaque français
sans leur consentement être public ou la
presse est créé 120 % du pic de dettes
publiques noël à la fin oui c'est pas
mal mais compte tenu de ce qui se passe
en ce moment on va être à 124 125 à la
fin et on va être à 130-140 très très
vite donc c'est pour l'instant 36000
euros pour chaque français est donc le
il faut complètement changer le logiciel
et comme il ya prenons l'exemple de la
culture fermé des musées qui sont des
lieux clos resserré évidemment mais la
fermeture de versailles la fermeture de
chantilly la fermeture de
vaux-le-vicomte la fermeture des
châteaux de la loire
tout ça n'a aucun sens c'est des
endroits où d'abord il ya une grande
partie a visité à l'extérieur où il ya
aucun problème et ont par ailleurs les
espaces sont gigantesques donc il suffit
il ya quand même eu et on ne tient aucun
compte par exemple des progrès faits par
le numérique simplement il faut vous
dire que maintenant les visites
effectivement le monde a changé pour
visiter il faut s'inscrire il faut
réserver par internet
et puis on a un un moment bien précis où
on arrive où on visite par petits
groupes
et si on respecte pas ce créneau ben on
a perdu ça on a perdu c'est même dans
les musées d'ailleurs on peut ici tous
les six mois et est qu'il ya des
musée par ailleurs le louvre ou autre il
ya quand même des hectares et des
hectares place on peut là aussi
s'organiser mais c'est là où geoffroy de
roux de bézieux a raison c'est à dire
que la logique c'est la priorité c'est
de fermer et la dette publique c'est
énorme cloche subi souviendra tout ça
c'est une logique qui est en train de
tuer le pays et de tuer également les
citoyens
donc on arrête avec les quoi qu'il en
coûte où est on est on est d'accord
encore une fois - c'est pas pour une
raison ou simplement budgétaire mais on
est d'accord là dessus il est très bien
dit nicolas baverez ce pas seulement
entre sont en train de tuer l'économie
mais aussi la société la culture notre
art de vivre
donc je crois que c'est pas c'est pas
raisonnable d'autant plus que cette vie
sous cloche n'est pas toujours justifiée
sur les musées ça a été très bien dit
vous allez même c'est de même
contre-productif peut-être sanitairement
legends sera peut-être mieux aller se
balader dans les jardins de versailles
que dette dans des appartements parfois
grille et le confinement parce que c'est
ce que certains font et se retrouver
dans des petits appartements à plusieurs
donc tout ceci est en plus
contre-productif là où je suis j'abonde
encore une fois dans le sens de nicolas
l'avouer ce que je pense que le gros
problème de la france c'est le déficit
de sa balance commerciale est
effectivement je crains que le dans
cette crise se soit on nous avait promis
de relocaliser la production de
reproduire en fois en france de régler
ce problème de dépendance
je ne vois rien venir système on a un
commissaire au plan
mais je ne sert pas à grand chose pour
le moment si ce n'est à donner à auch et
à françois bayrou
alors voici quelques réflexions de nos
internautes lumière sur youtube qui nous
affirme que la culture et loisirs c'est
vital pour le bien-être de l'être humain
boxe qui au contraire vous dis mais plus
les gens ont des raisons de sortir plus
il se contamine son excellent argument
donné aussi en disant qu' il faut ne pas
inciter les gens à bouger sauf
qu'apparemment c'est surtout chez soi
qu'on ce qu'on est susceptible
d'attraper lakovic 19 puis momo premier
qui vous interpellent nicolas baverez un
peu de sérieux monsieur baverel nous ne
sommes pas en asie pour maîtriser la
pandémie par la discipline
nous sommes en france mais enfin ça je
suis absolument pas d'accord avec ça
c'est à dire que c'est exactement le
raisonnement de nos gouvernants qui est
de dire que les français sont des
enfants et donc à partir du moment où on
a des citoyens qui ne sont pas des
adultes responsables
c'est à l'état d'interdire de supprimer
les libertés publiques et d'infantiliser
les gens je pense que c'est la meilleure
manière dont l'une est ce pays et que
s'il ya un renversement à faire
aujourd'hui si on veut reconstruire ce
pays
il faut être clair on ne reconstruira
qu'avec ses citoyens et donc c'est pas
en leur expliquant que ce sont des
irresponsables des incapables et que
qu'on y arrivera donc aujourd'hui il
faut faire l'inversé ça c'est très
important
une démocratie ça tient sur ses citoyens
ça se reconstruit sur ses citoyens
aujourd'hui la france est dans l'état de
elle est à reconstruire elle est à
reconstruire en expliquant aux français
en leur tenant un discours de vérité et
de courage et et qui équivaut pour
l'école épidémique comme il vaut pour
l'économie et qu'au niveau pour la
démocratie
je suis d'accord là-dessus effectivement
d'autant plus qu' il faut faire
confiance aux citoyens c'est le principe
même de la démocratie tout simplement et
ensuite les élites n'ont pas fait leur
preuve dans la gestion de cette crise
calamiteuse de a à z
peut-être qu'ils feraient bien de au
lieu de prendre les gens pour des idiots
d'essayer de les écouter juste une demi
seconde à mot sur le vaccin parce qu'ils
possèdent tout à l'heure j'ai oublié de
le dire ah bon c'est vrai que ça va
peut-être nous retarder mais là encore à
la fois je pense qu'il faut faire preuve
de prudence il ya un doute sur l'astra
est née gars mais je trouve qu'on
s'interdit des solutions qui pourraient
être de bon sens vous parler à tous les
médecins tous vous disent que le
meilleur vaccin c'est le spoutnik le
vaccin oui je vois pas pourquoi on le
commercialisera pas en europe je pense
que c'est pour des raisons purement
idéologique et entendre et je pense que
il faut le prendre des mesures parfois
disent que tirer je vois pas pourquoi on
pourrait pas acheter des vaccins à
poutine
on achète bien toute la production du
monde aux chinois qu'ils soient en
régime au moins aussi dur que celui de
potiers à mon avis beaucoup plus et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous dit éduenne
sur lefigaro.fr pourquoi la france
n'at-elle pas le vaccin spotlight pas
parce que la france a décidé de suivre
la solidarité européenne et donc la
procédure c'est qu'il faut d'abord que
ce vaccin soit homologué par les
autorités sanitaires européennes ce qui
est en cours on sait pas quand ça
arrivera peut-être étiez-vous devant
votre petit écran vendredi soir pour
suivre la cérémonie des césar la
profession s'est surpassée vendredi
dernier nous avons eu un doigt
je crois tous les poncifs leçon qu'on en
a oublié aucun du gauchisme culturel la
vulgarité en plus et si vous avez raté
ce moment d'anthologie
voici un résumé alex young pourrait
sceller ce que vous retenez que quatre
anciens préfère le dire je sais pas il
est possible que mon intervention soit
un petit peu islamo-gauchiste vulgaire
c'est parce que j'ai dit [ __ ]
ben moi dans ma bouche bée j'ai envie de
parler de adama traoré de l'esclavagé a
été retenu comme crime contre l'humanité
en 2001 et que aujourd'hui sur l'espace
public
certaines personnes qui ont activement
participé au crime contre l'humanité
sont glorifiés par des statuts
et sûr
alors comme l'a dit gérard jugnot le
lendemain sur rtl c'est dommage parce
que ça n'est pas ça qui va donner envie
aux gens de retourner au cinéma alors ce
que n'avait pas vu dans cette séquence
c'est la plainte constante de la
profession du cinéma qui souhaiteraient
recommencé à avoir une activité sans
jamais dire que cette profession est
l'une de celles qui est le plus
subventionné par l'état
d'abord tout au long de l'année et en
période normale et encore plus depuis le
début de la crise le statut des
intermittents qui permet ainsi à tous
les professionnels d'être payés comme
s'ils travaillaient leur permet de tenir
jusqu'à août 2000 jusqu'à août prochain
et ça a coûté un milliard d'euros à
l'état
les ailes exceptionnelle à la filière
ayant coûté 270 millions d'euros
nicolas baverez on se demande quand on
écoute la profession s'il faut continuer
à donner autant d'argent au cinéma
français et je crois que c'est une
cadets col des limites du quoi qu'il en
coûte
on en parlait à l'instant donc c'est
vrai que le cinéma est d'habitude en
régime de croisière déjà largement
subventionnés et c'est vrai que il a
continué à être subventionné
ils surent subventionné parce que on a
produit deux cents films en 2020 qui
n'ont pas de débouchés et qui va il est
voir un énorme embouteillage quand les
choses vont se rouvrir
et là je crois que ça traduit quand même
de la part de cette profession un double
mépris d'abord pour le public parce que
ce qui a été montré hier est vendredi un
pardon vendredi et est absolument
indigne et pour l'état et donc le
contribuable finalement les deux seuls
qui ont surnagé j'allais dire c'est la
ministre qui a enduré tout ça
avec qui pour le coup a fait preuve de
résilience et et puis ce qui était
dommage c'est que pavot à terme au même
genre était elle fait preuve de dignité
oui mais c'était c'était fait pour
obtenir son départ donc je trouve que de
ce point de vue là elle a assez bien
déjouer le pronostic
mais ce qui est surtout dommage c'est
que il faut être clair ce qu'on a dit il
va y avoir il ya une formidable
il ya un formidable appétit chez les
français de continuer à ar vir de
retrouver la culture le cinéma avait une
soirée qui est la soirée du cinéma une
occasion exceptionnelle de montrer que
le cinéma français est toujours vivant
qu'il a des choses positives
sympathique à apporter regardez ce qui
se passe aux etats unis dans le même
temps les grammy awards
ce sont des ces pays personne n'a j'ai
mis tout le monde était tendue vers le
positif et vers la manière de repartir
là c'était une une cérémonie des pleurs
absolument consternante effectivement
infondées et ce qui est dommage c'est
qu'en plus normalement s'était construit
pour célébrer la bande du splendid qui a
quand même fait rire des français depuis
des décennies et qui continue à les
faire rire et que ça aurait dû être ça
l'esprit de cette cérémonie
c'était d'une certaine manière on
regrette de ne pas avoir vu les bronzés
font du cinéma
au moins on aurait pas ça aurait donné
envie de ça aurait dans le donnait
environ
oui non on a eu la cmar ou parce que la
dernière fois j'avais fait un papier en
disant que le cinéma était otage des
minorités les petits rastignac du
communautarisme pour ça qu'on ne pouvait
pas toucher encore plus le fond est là
où on a été effectivement encore plus
loin une soirée totalement totalement
victimaire donneuse de leçons aussi
parce que on peut penser que voilà les
artistes surtout ceux qui sont à césar
sont quand même pas les plus à plaindre
justement et ils font du ld il donne des
leçons
de morale de politique au reste de la
population je crois pas que c'est leur
rôle leur rôle c'est de divertir de
faire rêver et là effectivement ça n'a
pas été le cas
voilà est-ce que c'est pour ça qu'il
faut jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
peut-être là où je leur en veut le plus
c'est qu'ils ont signé la branche sur
laquelle il était il ya six mois je
crois que j'aurais sans doute des choses
à voir en terme de subventions mais que
c'est pas fondamentalement un mauvais
principe ça nous a permis de d'avoir une
production cinématographique même de
produire à peu près l'essentiel de ce
qui se fait en europe il y avait un
grand cinéma italien elle est
aujourd'hui produit en partie grâce aux
subventions françaises et c'est donc ces
voix là je suis parfois navré par l'état
de cinéma françaises parce que s'il
pourra être plus intéressant qu'il ne
l'est mais on a encore une production
avec quelques bons films qui émerge
l'une des bonnes surprises de la soirée
était le palmarès moi j'ai trouvé que
les prix comme l'année dernière
d'ailleurs où finalement on avait un
spectacle désastreuse politique point
sur scène et finalement me promène
polanski avait été primé ceux qui
avaient voté avait jugé que la repasser
à vendresse non pas que je défende
paulin polanski et sur ce qu'il a fait
mais on a eu un palmarès qui était
finalement type politiquement correct
est là adieu les conquis qui était un
titre bien choisis je trouve pour pour
la soirée est un bon film qui mérite
d'exister qui aurait pas peut-être
existé sur le situation je pense que le
principe est beau ensuite il est sans
doute à revoir
il a sans doute été énormément dévoyé
qui donne les subventions au cnc à qui
on a parfois l'impression qu'elles sont
distribués aux copains sur des critères
qui sont voilà pas forcément
cinématographique d'autant plus que
maintenant on ajoute à ça des critères
diversiterre et c'est donc ce qu'on a vu
aussi les plaintes
il ya une dimension idéologique mais il
ya une dimension totalement j'ai envie
de dire intéressés et opportuniste
convoi arrivait on avait vu la même
chose aux victoires de la musique avec
des discours antiraciste bien lourdingue
l'année dernière aux césars il avait
compté les noirs dans la salle
chaque année il ya des gens issus de
différentes origines caisson qui sont
pris mais on semble pas vouloir en tenir
compte et à chaque fois on fait un
procès en racisme au cinéma français
c'est parce qu'il ya une espèce de vélo
d'idéologie d'hiver 6 et interphone qui
entre s'imposer mais aussi parce que
c'est un moyen très claire de palper des
subventions d exister et c'est donc
c'est vrai que le système est pervers et
pervertit est-ce qu'il faut tout arrêter
je n'en suis pas sûr je pense qu'il faut
la senior plus tôt mais c'est vrai que
plutôt que la soirée des césars c'était
la soirée des néron jouant de la lyre
devant l' incendie drôme vers 60 c'est
pour çà a considéré sur twitter quand on
vous pose la question qu'il ne faut pas
continuer à subventionner le cinéma
français ajoute que c'est sur le prix de
la parce qu'on n'a pas dit sur le gros
des subventions c'est le prix de la
salle de cinéma
quand vous achetez votre ticket il ya
une partie qui est reversée au cinéma
français voilà et une partie qui vient
de canal+ qui d'ailleurs est moins bien
payés un peu moins à l'occasion de deux
des renégociations qui sont en cours
anonyme
nous hisser francs on peut partager
l'esprit d'escalier
nicolas baverez se disaient les films
ont pas être débouchées ils ont eu quand
même un peu sur les plates formes etc
on peut éventuellement faire payer aussi
les plateformes faire preuve
d'imagination et franco français d'audi
anonyme le cinéma est à l'image des
français
je boycotte les productions françaises
nous dit clairement ac scène nicole 06
vulgaire politisé idéologique quel
spectacle dit elle aux en allusion à
cette cérémonie des césar madame
bachelot par son silence a été très
digne donc et la ceppm 75 qui est
d'accord avec vous cher nicolas son
silence devant ce ramassis de vulgarité
était la seule classe de cette soirée
et puis il ya cette réflexion
intéressante iran bien avoir votre avis
là-dessus
nicolas baverez hugo sur youtube nous
dit le sujet ne devrait pas porter sur
la nature du financement mais davantage
sur comment retrouver un niveau
d'excellence mais est ce que c'est le
meilleur moyen de rendre service à une
filière économique que de la
subventionner
est-ce que ça n'entraîne pas au
contraire à forme de mépris pour le
spectateur et pour le client puisque
toute façon l'argent tombe tout seul je
crois qu'au delà du problème de la
subvention parce que c'est vrai qu'on
peut considérer que la subvention vient
compenser un déséquilibre notamment par
rapport aux productions américaines
puisque le marché beaucoup plus petit
mais les vrais problèmes surtout n'ont
jamais été abordé puisque l'on vient
d'en parler
quel est le problème du cinéma le
problème du cinéma c'est évidemment le
basculement du numérique
l'arrivée des plateformes le
désengagement de canal + qui est l'autre
gros financeur avec la taxe hurler sur
les sur les billets et donc normalement
c'est vrai que c'est pas dans une
cérémonie des césar qui traiter ça mais
la cérémonie et les faits pour
rassembler une industrie il donnait
envie de consommer des films ça on est
passés spectaculairement à côté et
al'inverse cette profession au lieu de
passer son temps uniquement à quémander
des fonds publics devraient s'intéresser
à la partie industrielle et à son modèle
économique
et ça je vais pas d'autres qu'il est
complètement repensé et que pour
l'instant la seule réponse des
professionnels c'est l'état doit nous
donner plus d'argent et ça c'est une
erreur fondamentale parce que par
ailleurs cet état il à 120% du pic de la
dette publique
donc monsieur que j'ai pressé voilà et
donc tout ce qui explique que
leur avenir dans les prochaines
décennies prochaine c'est de recevoir
plus d'argent de l'état tout cela sont
en train de se vouer à la disparition
il aurait pu il ya une protestation
comme moi j'attendais co finalement on a
très peu vu
moi j'aurais trouvé légitime qui
demandent la réouverture des salles de
cinéma des salles de spectacles dans la
mesure du possible etc
ça a été très peu vu donc on a réclamé
des subventions mais pas simplement de
vivre de son travail ce qui est toujours
préférable ensuite philosophiquement on
peut se dire l'artiste c'est son talent
qui doit porter un artiste subventionné
on n'imagine pas subventionner picasso
ou mozart ou que sage philosophiquement
balzac c'est ou balzac c'est un
raisonnement philosophique mozart
raisonnement que je sombre mais je
n'observe j'observe je vois qu'il y
avait un cinéma italien gelé revient
resplendissant avec fellini visconti et
tous les autres qu'il a totalement
disparu que nous on a quelques grands
auteurs qui continua à travailler on en
fait travailler d'autres j'insiste en
europe
canal + diffuse les films donc c'est pas
totalement et stupide qui les financent
donc je pense que c'est une idée qui
n'est pas fondamentalement mauvaise mais
encore une fois ça nécessite une
réflexion sur l'industrie et sans doute
voilà on réformer ça en profondeur mais
pas forcément le sacrifier merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous
demain
bonsoir
[Musique]